extreme heat across the country and it's
not just unpleasant it's dangerous
around 120 million americans that's more
than a third are facing excessive heat
warnings and advisories today and it's
no better in europe unheard of
temperatures and drought conditions are
generating devastating wildfires chris
van cleave is in dallas where it's
expected to be close to 110 degrees for
the second day in a row chris good
morning
well good morning nearly the entire
state of texas 99 percent is
experiencing some kind of drought
condition that's only making it more
challenging for the firefighters
battling at least a dozen wildfires
across the lone star state and of course
the heat is taking an impact on critical
infrastructure and raising concerns
about the safety for people nationwide
scorched by unrelenting heat bone dry
texas brush is fueling wildfires across
the state nationwide approximately 85
are burning in 13 states charring more
than 3 million acres if you don't feel
safe you should leave
a fire at the cooper dam on the arizona
nevada border part of the hoover dam
briefly caught fire after a transformer
exploded in 109 degree heat the cause is
under investigation
and tragedy in this tallahassee parking
lot where police are looking for answers
after an 11 month old was found dead in
the back of a hot car potentially
marking at least the 12th hot car death
this year how quickly can this kind of
heat impact a person
it can impact them in a matter of
minutes
in fort worth ems agency medstar is
providing donated air conditioning units
to vulnerable residents like 86-year-old
wendy francis it makes a big difference
yeah
braving 110 degrees city repair crews
are working on one of nearly 200 water
mains that have burst in the last 30
days alone as temperatures consistently
hit triple digits the ground is drying
out and when it shifts
the water mains can break and now white
house officials are warning the heat
wave poses a larger threat climate
change is a national security
issue it takes away from other tasks and
missions whether it comes to defending
the united states
now there have been no reports of any
injuries linked to the wildfires but
several structures have been destroyed
you may notice we're getting a breeze
today feels good right now but the
national weather service is concerned
that that only elevates the risk for
significant fire danger across texas
the dallas area will get a bit of a
break tomorrow when temperatures could
dip below 100 degrees at least for the
day if you can call 98 a cool down tony
you can call it a cool down but not much
of a break chris thank you very much